comédie française troisième semaine
consécutive de grève totale enfin de 20
heures en 24 heures ce qui veut dire que
tous les spectacles sont annulés d'un
jour sur l'autre à l'exception des
matinée du mercredi et du dimanche
réduit au chômage technique les
comédiens du français ont annoncé
aujourd'hui qu'ils allaient jouer
ailleurs michel vial lier pour les
comédiens français s'appelle le théâtre
de la porte saint-martin qui devrait
accueillir à partir du 27 avril la
création des femmes savantes suivi d'une
reprise d'estaires ce n'est évidemment
pas de gaieté de coeur que les
sociétaires du français ont pris cette
décision répond en fait à la nécessité
d'assumer leur mission vis-à-vis du
public autant qu à l'impératif d'assurer
la pérennité de leur prestigieuse maison
car paradoxalement les clés du conflit
échappe aux comédiens pourtant les
premiers concernés
elles apparaissent plutôt aux mains des
pouvoirs publics qui ont accordé il y a
deux ans à l'opéra de paris une nouvelle
convention collective avec augmentation
de salaire et réduction des horaires de
travail
une convention collective sur laquelle
les machinistes et les tapissiers de la
comédie française demande à être alignés
terrible dilemme pour l'administration
du français sensibles à uré est la
justice salariale mais non habilitées à
satisfaire les grévistes est contrainte
rigueur oblige à la fermeté d'où
l'impasse actuelle et un bilan
préoccupant
trente représentations annulées soit une
perte de 1 million 600 mille francs dont
l'évaluation ne prend pas en compte le
malaise des comédiens leur départ leur
exil pourrait-on dire vers d'autres
salles n'est donc qu'un pis-aller décidé
sans volonté d'affrontements en vérité
dans la tente d'une médiation voire
d'une solution qui manifestement
dépassant la circonstance la maison de
molière